i'm at 65 years old and i'm still out
here
uh getting high on the streets of
kensington how long you been out here uh
this time three years how long you been
out here total well
over 30 years
yeah 30 years how was kensington changed
oh
really bad it's horrible it's that
everybody lives in the streets they uh
they rob you they beat you up you know
it's really horrible if you're not with
somebody you know
and you're done you're really done for
it
you know they fall asleep they take your
sneakers off your feet you told me when
i picked you up there were two girls
that promoted recently yeah two girls
were murdered here well actually
more than two but two girls that really
stand out to me are the ones that were
tied to a board
uh and wired onto it and i believe one
of them was
beheaded
but they were both uh raped
you know in murder
and this was like in the last two three
weeks
yeah there's a few things going on a few
shootings those shootings every night
every night there you just hear the
gunshots
yeah yes i mean and
one time we were standing on the corner
you know we were cupping i'm not going
to lie and
that may come up and rob them of the
of a few bundles of dope
and he started running through the park
and they just started shooting
i mean we had to run hide under get
under a car
because they were just randomly shooting
it that didn't matter which way or you
know what i mean it's a shoot any which
way you know it doesn't matter they just
it's really horrible out here it's you
know i was hospitalized in january i had
a uh
they called a mess
when you don't get the veins it's like
an abscess yeah well they said it didn't
turn into an abscess but it could have
but i had i started as a pimple got a
little bigger and then i taken my coat
off and hear the skin peeled and i had a
a hole
like the size of a silver dollar and it
almost went
straight clear to the other side of my
hand and they hospitalized me for 10
days
they detoxed me and
here i am again
you know i got out of the hospital and
said i was there for 10 days
and it took
four days and i was right back
right back
the sickness when you get sober
it's horrible it's really horrible
there's like
you listen whenever anybody doesn't feel
good what do you think that was getting
better right
and and that's just you know how it is
with an addict you know your drug is
fentanyl yes fentanyl and once your eyes
might crack
you know i'm not gonna lie i don't drink
or anything like that
but uh yeah my drug is fentanyl
was heroin but you know that was taken
off the streets but this stuff they got
out here
has
bugs or something in it they said it's
eating us
they put meat tenderizer in it
all kinds of stuff so it's eating us
inside alps
and that's how we form these sewers
[Music]
i have one still on my leg
you know it's just a scab now but it
takes a while like i say i had it
uh
right at christmas time and like i said
the scab's still there but you know it
was taken care of you know
but it took me a little bit you know to
uh
like i said when the skin peeled off my
hand and i seen the hole
you know that that did me in i just said
i'm going to hospital and i went but um
yeah that
it's terrible out here you know but i
could say that and say that but i'm
still here
you know that drug is really powerful
you know we have cops constantly at us
and it doesn't matter
you know it just don't matter to us
it doesn't make sense tell me about your
childhood maggie what's that tell me
about your childhood i was like before
you start you have a mask on yeah can
you take that off please take it off
yeah just bring your pocket or something
yeah i um
i'm a number three of nine children
um
i um
i was raped at the age of five
by my 13 year old brother
and uh
nothing was ever sad about it my mother
seen and
said nothing about it you know it sent
me
so i lived through that all my life i
didn't mention it so i was 56 years old
and i believe that's part of why i do
use drugs
you know i just i didn't know what was
right and what was wrong
you know my five-year-old
little girl
quarantined in my bedroom because i had
scored a fever you know you can die from
that well years ago i'm sure you could
but now i'm sure it's a lot different i
was 50 some years ago but um
yeah
he raped me was 13 i was five
and nobody ever said anything you know
and when i said something about it my
mother denied that he was ever even home
you know
whatever
and you know the funny thing is my
mother passed
not this december the one before that
and uh she kept asking for me
i wasn't around she kept calling my
sister my name you know
asking for me and i got there
and see what ac passed
you know she had a big smile on her face
when my sister told her i was there you
know
i don't know she wanted to say something
to me or what you know i mean it's going
to bother me i guess the rest of my life
you know why she wanted me so bad
but you know like i said i grew up in
with nine children it was hard you know
my father was just a truck driver you
know my mother stayed home so all the
kids got older and then she went to work
you know but uh
it was hard
you know i babysat to make money you
know i bought my own sandals at the age
of 12. never had a pair of sandals so i
babysat and got my own you know and
i started working when i was 14.
i worked for the city of state the
government i was making uh hand grenades
during vietnam
where did you go to school
eleven eleventh grade yeah you have kids
yeah i have five children five i have
eleven grandchildren and four
great-grandchildren did you raise them
my children yeah well not for a couple
years i didn't raise uh
two of them one of them i had lost and
then got him back
and then he left me anyway he went back
to where he was living which was my
sister what's that one of them is here
in kensington with you yes yes my son
michael yes
and he's my little protector
you know
i don't know what i would do without him
i really don't and he's addicted to
fentanyl as well yes
yes
he was also in the hospital when i was
fentanyl is a huge thing here in
kensington oh i'm telling you honey it's
horrible and you know what sometimes
we're not even buying fentanyl i don't
know what it is
i really don't i mean a lot of times
we're just buying sleep medicines you
know when you pass that i just woke up
in the park i was asleep for an hour and
a
half
and i've already been
where they stole my shoes off my feet i
had to walk all the way to
you know fifth and the bet they
barefooted you know like last summer and
they stole everything my suit my brainy
shoes my sneakers my bag of clothes you
know i woke up and shooting everything
is going you know nobody knows nothing
you know but everybody's sitting around
watching each other in the park the park
is
uh the devil himself you know uh
just shamelessly so many people fall
you know and uh
i keep telling my son to go away to
rehab he's like mom i'm not leaving you
i said but michael you go i have a son
in prison
he was in an accident a couple years ago
he hit somebody it was an accident it
was raining real bad he was on the air
tracks the trolley tracks and a slid
guy come between two cars
and on a bicycle and my son tried to get
out away and he hit him well he went
over the guy said he was okay my son was
staying at a uh
like a halfway house he had to be in by
10 so he ran to the halfway house it was
right around the corner almost from
where he hit the guy and they wouldn't
let him back out so they got him for
leaving the scene of a crime
he's actually tomorrow's birthday he's
going to be 45.
you know
it's hard
you know and i think that keeps me
going you know what i mean subsides my
uh
my feelings
i haven't seen them in
for seven years
you know
they have ever ride
or why i can't get nobody to say
i don't know
but support his birthday
before he's fine he's got
five children
he's had four grandkids while he's been
away
a good kid so he really is
but uh yeah i've been out here i've lost
so much
you know got it back lost it again you
know
but uh
you know it's just so hard and i have
children that use
actually my oldest son he
he
he was a user too
the only reason why i guess he's still
because he's away whatever but
i hate to even say that one you know
heir but
people know
you know my mother was the one that
knocked on nobody like nobody knows
you know what i mean and i'm not like
that you know it is what it is you know
but uh
like my son that's with me michael he's
he's a good kid he was in and out of
jail but for the last three years he
hasn't been a job
you know
i mean i feel good in a way because i
keep him with me you know
he won't leave me he won't leave me
anyway but you know anyway now i'm
starting to feel bad
you know like he won't leave because
i'm out here you know
and i was telling him today i'm like i
want you to go away and get yourself
together you know you're only 30 years
old i'm 65 you know i'm towards my end
you know what i mean but uh
he has two children he hasn't seen them
either you know it's a shame
what happens to us in life you know
and they say you know
addiction is hereditary it really is my
father was an alcoholic
but not long but it's in the genes you
know and that much my older brother was
a
[ __ ] he had a room toward arthritis
all his life he just died uh two years
ago he fell broke his neck and shattered
his windpipe
and they told me he had a 25 chance of
coming out of the operation and
he told them now and my sisters were on
their way there and uh they called and
said
don't rush he he passed
he was seven he was in a wheelchair it's
the one that's greatly
you know that brother
yeah
but uh you know i i don't even feel bad
i didn't even go to his funeral
did you ever talk to him about what
happened when you're done no
never talk to him about it
even when i came out with it i was going
to go there and and i thought you know
what what's the sense
you know and plus he's got guns and
stuff and
even next time you're going to shoot me
i don't know but you know and i thought
and i didn't want to upset my mom
anymore you know
my mom passed away she was 89 years old
bless her soul they nor candor
why would you nor i can't an 89 year old
woman
and she died
and a few days after that she didn't eat
drink nothing
walker nothing since they don't care you
know these paramedics as soon as
something happens right away they narcan
you know i mean there was a guy
two days ago okay and they were
he was taking the seizure right away
they were in an arcane him
you don't even know what's happening
with the guy you're going to give him no
i can't you know what i mean he wasn't
even high that's what they all said he's
not getting high he's taking a seizure
but what happened i think was they seen
a prescription of percocets in my mom's
medicine
but supposedly they were like 90 pills
there was only eight missing in a
three-month period so she wasn't abusing
them you know what i mean but as soon as
they see or hear or this section you get
narcan it's horrible it really is and
that's not a good feeling i've been
narcan
it's not good you've a dude before
what's that you've odd before yes yeah
not too long ago right after i got
silver and started getting high again
you think you can come back out and do
the same as you was same amount okay
starting over yeah and i didn't realize
that you've been using opiates for how
long
oh
30 years
yeah
30 years off and on you know at one time
i had eight years uber
were you raising your kids while you're
using
uh not really
not well as they got when they got older
they were with me you know what i mean
but they pretty much took care of
themselves i'm not saying i i stayed in
the streets or anything i was this is
like
i'd say it's the second time i've been
in the streets homeless you know what
i'm saying but uh
i
was homeless before and the kids were
with my sister and my mom and dad had
helped take care of the three younger
ones my older ones were you know older
because i have children 47 41 i'll be 45
and then it's 32
30 and 26.
is this the lowest point in your life
right now what's that is this the lowest
point of your life
very very bad
i mean i never imagined being homeless
this long
you know and they say there's help out
there
there's really not help i see these
people get this housing and i i'm
getting you know an income now
and they have uh
low income housing you know you pay a
third of what you get for your housing i
can't even get on that
i don't know i don't know what you have
to do you know what i mean to get this
help
i mean i've been i've been on lists
all that
but actually i'm lying
okay because
two years ago when the pua was going on
okay
we were staying what's that what's the
pua i think it's pu isn't it where
everybody was getting that uh
unemployment money okay okay we were
staying under an acme up at second in
gerard and here there was a fire and the
people i was keeping in contact with and
they would come and bring us food and
stuff
i was running this list and here they
came to get me when they found out the
fire they couldn't find us even the
supervisor come out they had housing for
me and they couldn't find us so now i
get put back on the bottom of the list
like i don't understand that you know i
mean if if if it's your time it's your
time you know what i mean
but i'm back one of the last i don't
know how long it'll take there's so many
people in kensington so many people are
addicted to drugs living homeless in
kensington what do you why do you think
that is
why do i think why do you think that is
oh
thought of that you know
i guess uh it's not just a few hundred
people oh why not it's there's a lot of
people on i believe i know a lot of
people i mean everywhere i go people
know me
and i'm not saying it's even from for
being out here for all them years
i mean i i i meet new people every day
and they don't forget that
you know what i'm saying they really
don't i could walk down the street in a
normal neighborhood you know and talk to
somebody for a week and i walk down the
street two weeks later they won't even
remember me but these people remember
i don't know
the reason why i guess
i guess it's because there's low income
that's when i always thought you know
with the drugs coming in low income you
know what i mean they were able to make
money
you know and that's a big part of it
yeah and you know they used to have this
thing
he went from welfare to mayfair mayfair
department of philadelphia you know what
i mean it's like you're moving on up you
know what i mean you went from welfare
to mayfair but i never did that
but i was married twice
uh
you didn't love excuse me you were in
love yes yeah twice and my first husband
was a vietnam veteran
uh
that was a little rough
i mean it was a lot my husband my first
husband beat me and raped me for 10
years
he would do it right in front of my kids
my two older kids you know it didn't
matter to him
and
then i remarried
when i was 41 that lasted eight years
and
uh he was a great guy he really is uh so
is
uh he owned a uh
a sober club you know everybody went
there that was sober you know you played
a pool and there was karaoke and stuff
like that that was a nice spot but
i loved them but i wasn't in love
you know
it was great to my kids my grandkids
they all loved them the pieces you know
what i mean he was a great guy he really
was
but i wasn't in love with him and i
didn't think that was fair being fair to
him
you know
yeah with this uh accountant thing i
think it's going to halt
they're locking so many people up on it
it's really crazy
i mean they were in the park two days
ago you couldn't even have
paraphernalia and they were locking up
you know it was really crazy
and i believe they're still going to do
that
task force is all over the place they're
in plain clues you don't know who i try
to send you
you don't have the cop
but i know
maggie what do you what are you afraid
of now what do you worry about what do i
worry about
well of course i always worry about my
children but um
i worry about where i sleep at night
you know where do you sleep at night i
sleep in
port richmond
you have an apartment no no it's in the
street baby it's in the street we put
cardboard around us and
just hope nobody bothers us you know
but like i say i have my son i mean i
know he's not god but he does help me a
lot you know
i you know i feel safe when i'm with him
and when he's not around i don't feel
safe at all
but if you had your whole life to live
all over again what would you have done
differently
oh wow
oh
well
you know what i think i would have
stayed so uh single
you know
and i brought children into the world
and hurt them
saying
i know i've hurt my kids
you know
i know i have
yeah i think i would
stay single not have no children so i
can't hurt nobody
i know i heard my parents a lot
my dad was my best friend
he passed away like 24 years ago my dad
and like i said my mom passed away
2021 december 5th
if it was appearances that were i can't
say anything you have to do with them
you know what i mean
i think this way from life's terms
uh to me you know
growing up with
eight siblings
is hard
you know with one working painter and
my dad worked hard you know he was a
trump sorry
which
he pretty much worked at the
in the docks but uh
he went to work every day you know every
night he worked work
my mom stayed home and took care of us
you know
she didn't go to work and so all of us
were growing you know
but yeah i think
if i had to do all i would have any
children but god bless
i wouldn't give them away for him for
anything but
you know just i didn't hurt them and i
know my one daughter
she can't stand me
you know she can't stand me
you know
a little boy got blossomed with such a
sweetheart
and
she yeah
she heard last year that i was dead
and
she messaged me
please tell me you're not dead
so i touched her back but she don't
wanna
you know what
i can't stay sober for nobody but myself
i gotta need i gotta want
you know
and i thought i really wanted it in
january when it went to the hospital
but i just didn't feel good
it put me on suboxone and
now it just
didn't do me
you know
how do you think all these years you
spent on the streets have has changed
you no god has changed me i was
i started out as a model when i was a
baby i'm out of baby clothes
i was a bit late dancer for 25 years
maybe i'd be on broadway
not this way
but yeah
like i say i work for the city to state
the the government
i've had some really good jobs but threw
it all away
and you know what when i thought you
were saying this and the other sent me
my first husband i think destroyed me
i really do you destroyed you
yeah
by beating me raping me in front of my
kids all of you 10 years
i told my mom what was happening she
told me i made my bed late
but my mom had kids still you know
like i'm 11 years older than the twins
that was her baby the twins you know but
uh
do you feel like life is unfair
sometimes i made my own bad baby like my
mom said you molested as a five-year-old
girl by your brother oh yeah that's
that was horrible yes
it was christmas eve so i
was watching cartoons
forced into snowman and stuff
and that's what it was he wanted me to
turn the tv off
then it was laying here with me you know
in case it was
terrible right
what was your favorite memory
my favorite memory
[Music]
i guess happened my children
do you have friends now
i have friends yeah
in the park
if that's what you're called for just
street acquaintances what's that those
are just street equations
i'm really friends-wise now i don't even
bother like i say with my family
my brother was just in an accident and
uh got over 200 stitches in his head he
broke his femur
it was his birthday from what i heard
and i mean i know it was his birthday
but he was at i guess partying and he
was in the back seat and he got
the the mess of it all he can't walk or
nothing right now he's 54 years old
yeah
but my uh
i don't know i couldn't even say what i
loved him when i ballet that was
i should have stayed with him just i
even ballet when i was pregnant i even
did water ballet and everything i loved
it
i used to teach i used to teach little
football players
you know just a little things for uh
endure endorsement and stuff you know
but yeah they thought i don't want to do
that that's for girls
yeah some good memories i guess
what's your biggest regret
picking that drug up for the first time
yes i started out on percocets
yeah it was an accident and i
started using them and
i had children and
they made me feel better so i kept doing
them and they owned them and then she
got to be too expensive i mean i'm doing
25s at one time
you know i puke them up rinse them off
and take them again you know like
that's disgusting right
i raised my hand i did it you know
and that's a lot of money at a time you
know
they're a fighter they're five dollars a
piece and you figure i'm doing 20
two and three times a day that's a lot
of money
i used to ride the getaway car
that's something funny i was bonnie
yeah because i can't i can't steal i
just can't do that
i really cannot take nothing
i can't go into a store like all this
stuff that's going on around here
christmas time you should have been
around here
these people are walking around with all
kinds of stuff they go in the store and
take and leave and the store they
couldn't do nothing
you can't do nothing
i don't understand that
that's stealing
i don't know
that's crazy and you should have seen
when they did the looting on omegle
abbey oh my god i don't know if you've
seen it on tv or whatever but ah they
destroyed them stewards
maggie what do you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
65 years
the most important lesson i've learned
since
i guess never to pick up a drug
but and i keep using i don't know why
think a lot of it just has to do with
this thing that happens in me in my life
no
you know like the five-year-old saying
the thing being married to my first
husband you know and he walked around
like he didn't do nothing wrong
i'd have birthday parties for my kids
and my family would come over like my
one daughter she was born december 16th
so i was like right before christmas you
know and they all made sure they always
came for you know what i mean she didn't
get neglected because of christmas and
he would start all this bull crap you
know and they don't wind up leaving you
know what i mean that was my daughter's
name you know
he didn't care
he really didn't care
and they claimed it was all because he
was in vietnam i don't know i think it
was just a mental thing all the way
around you know
somebody do that to their kids
we would go out christmas night i'd come
home
gifts and the tree be on the porch
and he stays so visible
right
and i don't want to sound like i use
that as an excuse
because i hate when people use that for
an excuse it's not an excuse
i just don't like to feel
i really don't like to feel anymore
and that takes all your feelings away it
really does
it's horrible
and i wanted
a four great-grandchildren i haven't
even seen
i mean i've seen my one the last one i
haven't seen
my uh
granddaughter was that little boy
but i mean i know he was born and
everything but i haven't seen
but the other ones i have
and my grandchildren they're all good
kids they really are thank god they're
not on drugs oh god
i think they learn from
me and
you know their parents and everything
else you know
anything else you want to know
[Laughter]
all right maggie thank you so much for
sharing your story
with that thank you so much for sharing
your story
no problem
thank you i wish you the best of luck
out there thank you thank you
you